[Music]
holy [ __ ] you guys man we i was like i
was talking and talking and talking and
then tom's like i think this [ __ ] shut
off like a long time ago yeah because i
went out of the show and tried to go
back in and says where's there a live
stream and we did like [ __ ] 15
minutes of show
and it was a bunch of funny [ __ ] yeah
and then i was like go look at part two
and see where we ended up and i was like
oh my god that was like [ __ ] 15
minutes ago i don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening holy [ __ ] guys you guys
lost like 15 minutes a pretty good show
well i'm gonna have to go start over
we're gonna have to like pretend that we
didn't even do that we had to fix all
this yeah we're gonna go back and like
[ __ ] man it cut off when we were
talking about pumpkin spice that was
like ages long time ago yeah
man i talked about all kind of [ __ ]
without that guy okay good might as well
back up this is making me so so mad yeah
i told him i was almost all the crowd we
got like six people i told him i was
like this makes me so angry because we
don't usually have this much more
problem yeah
and
i always kind of feel like look we go
off on a lot of tangents that's just it
happens um
you know i get annoyed but whatever
and it's just kind of like so i'm like
maybe like a third of the way through
and i'm like man i have so much like
[ __ ] left to talk about yeah and
the more that it gets
that it like cuts off the angrier i get
and like the angrier i get
and the more i have to wait like the
more i'm gonna drink because i'm pissed
off and i'm waiting and i hate waiting
for stuff because i'm really impatient
they're all sympathetic though and then
i'm just kind of like then by the time i
get to the end of it i'm just gonna be
slurring everything and it's not gonna
make any sense and i'm gonna have to
shut the [ __ ] up so she can get up i'm
getting loaded
part of the show is us fighting
fighting to get through the show once we
get like a couple hours into it because
of all the [ __ ] alcohol we drink
but i don't know i kind of think about
it the next day i'm like should we even
be drinking on the show because maybe
but then i'm like well no because that's
kind of like the fun of it then like
half the people are like why aren't you
guys drinking all the [ __ ]
it's like i always kind of feel like
it's difficult and i get frustrated but
then i'm like yeah but it's kind of more
fun the university program it's kind of
more fun this is an entertainment i like
that it goes into like all of these
unexpected directions that's kind of fun
we need a way to let you guys know the
stream for oh it went red again oh it's
going [ __ ] red again god damn it
don't you do it cut it off very abruptly
it's back it's back it's trying to come
back it's bad i mean i don't know why
we're having so much trouble
we don't usually have this much trouble
god i have so much [ __ ] left to talk
about and it's like now i'm scared
if this [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuts off and we don't come back we just
got sick of it
[Laughter]
we just got sick of it yeah no it's just
because i can look at that stream look
how bad that's getting
maybe they are doing maybe they are
doing like maintenance although i
thought it was like the middle of the
night that they were gonna do it
now i'm like afraid to talk because it's
like i'm sure it's not gonna like
[ __ ] back to green
yeah with the
[ __ ] i think they're doing maintenance
on this thing tonight
murder hornet says tom send me that
cookbook
all right i'll send you one
let me know i gotta like [ __ ] order
yeah
y'all we're up to like law and order
okay it's green
okay should we see how it goes so let's
we're gonna try to finish the show
people i mean man i was like talking
about like yogurt in people's butts and
everything yeah he was putting he was
telling people to eat a certain amount
of yogurt and put the other half up in
your ass
which that's like some fattest [ __ ] you
know i mean they got whole video whole
[ __ ]
websites on [ __ ] x videos and [ __ ]
to do that [ __ ] [ __ ] well yeah that's
a whole niche i'm sure yeah this is my
girlfriend she's going to eat this i'm
gonna put this up in her ass that they
got that
they got they got [ __ ] like that what
was in one of them what i was saying and
i'm sure this got cut off
what i was saying that it's like and and
i said well it's not crazy and tom's
like yeah it is crazy well i'm like yeah
it's crazy it's crazy but i understand
where he was coming from
his whole thing was that yogurt
had
um you know intestinal flora that was
like it was replacing your good gut
bacteria which is true
so he advocated you have a pint of
yogurt every day
you eat half of that pint and then the
other half of the pint goes guess where
up your butt yeah she's just crazy
which i well he was getting them for
both ends it's still crazy it's still
crazy yeah but i understand
it's still crazy don't get me wrong but
i understand where
he got the idea from
it does kind of make sense if you look
at it sort of cockeyed another thing is
is that
physicians from this era would tell you
to do some [ __ ] like this
and they would
promote this as if it will make you live
like 20 or 30 years longer
or that you know what i mean that it was
like a really big deal
there'd be a big difference oh [ __ ] look
at this strand
okay well i will say in his defense dr
kellogg lived till he was 91. yeah
but still the average person wouldn't
notice much no problem from what they're
doing there i mean yeah there'd be an
improvement with the diet of that age
but it wouldn't be much better than the
diet the average person who's listening
would have today it wouldn't be much
different well and genetics plays a part
too like some people can eat crap their
whole lives and they'll just live a long
time just because they're lucky some
people can eat healthy their whole life
um sometimes you just get you know
that's
it's statistical um obviously you should
live as healthy as reasonable
um you know don't overdo it though have
some fun
but
it genetics does play a part too oh yeah
well some people are going to die no
matter what yeah that's what i'm saying
[ __ ] up jeans you know you're [ __ ]
you live [ __ ] two hours after birth
because you got four heads
that's what i mean and you know and and
i've known we've known you know we had a
friend that uh died what's up yeah this
stream is god this is really it's oh
this is so frustrating oh man we're
getting red lights people we're just
losing so frustrating the chances of us
being able to finish this [ __ ] show
is gonna is
is going away jim
and it sucks because it's like man i i
[ __ ] spent so much time doing notes
and stuff like that
okay it's back to green
it just made that's what makes me angry
is that i spent so much time like and
then every time it's like [ __ ]
distracting every time i see the red
list like i get [ __ ] distracted and
it's like you know what i mean
uh rebecca says just go for it guys if
you get cut off we'll get over it you
can always just [ __ ] trash this
[ __ ] show and [ __ ] do it again
well i'm i'm gonna try to not do that or
do a part two on another week or
something well we're already on part
three because this [ __ ] shit's gone
camp guy says it's already been
processed and extracted by the time it
gets all the way down to your large
bowel no need to put it up your rear end
that's what i'm saying yeah just eat it
yogurt's good
um you don't have to put it you don't
have to shoot it up your butt yeah
unless you're into that if you're i'm
not judging i'm just saying yeah
but don't do it for health reasons just
do it because you like it
you know what i mean
yeah so uh so do we talk okay so his
whole thing was biologic living like i
said it was very seventh-day adventist
thing they were very my body is a temple
you have to like treat it like
you know
like a temple
as you do
so uh again that was one of the things
that made them want to do like bland
foods and stuff because as i said if
anything was like too spicy or sugary or
whatever then it would make you uh want
to have sex and that was like bad
so
that was uh something
now this is something that i talked
about extensively but i guess it got cut
off was that
and i don't think you were here so you
might find this interesting anyway but
dr kellogg was actually quite ahead of
his time in advocating
nuts
as like not those nuts but you know
let's let's not be 12 year old boys here
uh as a meat substitute
he is generally credited as being one of
the people that maybe developed like
some kind of uh innovation in the peanut
butter area i don't think he invented
peanut butter but he was one of the
people that was in there for that and he
was kind of like advocating a lot of
like nut butters
you know i mean like making a lot of
things out of nuts and he also made um
some stuff
nut it was called nattos or nut
nutelline or something like that nutty
lean
and that was actually supposed to be a
meat substitute like you used it the way
you would use
meat like you would season it the way
you would season meat and use it you
know it was a cream
um well it was kind of like a crunched
up
pate type situation
yeah
so he was kind of like one of the first
person to advocate
using nuts as a meat substitute like a
protein substitute
yeah which like i said very very ahead
of its time because nowadays people take
that for granted
but back then that would have been kind
of uh weird
but he was kind of on the honest people
cuss you need to substitute your meat
with peanuts no
would it be okay to sub to suck with
peanut
yeah yeah sure nuts are actually quite
good for you and uh i'm i love nuts in
general variety is always good for the
human body variety of [ __ ] food
intake you know i mean yeah you don't
want to be stuck on one thing in the
1800s man they didn't have much variety
so any variety would have been an
improvement so he is onto something
yeah change up your [ __ ] diet
yeah like i said he was more like
weirdly he seemed like more low pre
protein guy
but he was very into like your bowels
cleaning your bowels and how to get into
my bowels
he's dead now so i don't think he's
gonna get it no no i'm not like that i
like it he was very into like grains and
vegetables it's which is good like i
said that's good and he did seem to have
a plan for
meat substitution because
they didn't you know they didn't like uh
prohibit eating meat they just
discouraged it they discouraged more
like vegetarian but that's why yeah
that's why he was kind of more into like
advocating nuts as a meat substitute let
me give this guy some modern knowledge
they called it
the the the [ __ ] keto diet
ketogenic diet which is nothing but just
[ __ ] red meat
a lot of bodybuilders have tried it i
[ __ ]
you know they they'll [ __ ] do shows
on it on [ __ ] youtube and everything
yeah you'll lose some fat lose a little
bit of weight you can gain some lean
muscle mass they feel like [ __ ] on it
uh your bowel movements are like [ __ ]
like you're crapping out grease all
right gross uh it's not good for your
[ __ ] um your lipids in your
bloodstream
and a lot of these people in the 1800s
were almost on a diet like that they're
just it wasn't a very diet meat and some
bread
so they would have been kind of in a
similar condition so he's on to
something he's taught but he's oh yeah
that's something that is a very diet you
should have a varied diet yeah human
beings are omnivores
like dogs and pigs or whatever you
should be eating a mixture of stuff
protein and [ __ ] vegetables and
[ __ ] you know starches and sugars and
you should have a bit of everything
don't
the problem is is when you start going
to this narrow band thing when you're
fixated on one thing like well i'm just
gonna eat nothing but damn meat no
that's not good i'm going to eat nothing
but just [ __ ] green vegetables no
that's not good either you're meant to
eat a variety of stuff
eat a bunch of different things there's
a bunch of stuff eat a bunch yeah and
depending on what you're trying to do
you know like a guy like me you're gonna
be heavy on meat but you want [ __ ]
vegetables and [ __ ] too it's all
you know
and protein you want a lot of protein
so
he's on to something he's not
bullshitting he you know he sees the
problem yeah he's seen it from the from
the viewpoint of a man of the 1800s sure
yeah which like i said uh from our point
of view uh some of this stuff actually
did seem quite ahead of its time yeah
some of the stuff was
crazy but
you know oh and we'll get into like some
more crazy well it's experimental
yeah because like i said this was odd
back i mean now everybody kind of takes
it for granted well obviously you know
we should eat a very diet you should eat
more vegetables you should eat more
fiber you should do that but back then
it wasn't really the common knowledge
yeah it wasn't about diet they knew
nothing about it so it was weird right
it was weird it was it was still kind of
like a fringe yeah uh type of thing no
no
diet that you're trying to survive on
should be extreme
extremes are not found in nature and
you're a product of nature
humans ate everything they ate
everything yeah that's well that's why
these kind of like diets that are always
kind of like we'll never eat this or
never eat that i'm like that's not gonna
work out go for it that's not gonna work
out honestly just eat a lot of things
just not a lot of it just eat like
moderation and you keep your activity
high high income weight lifting is
always better than cardio but cardio is
good it should be a mixture
it's you guys know what i'm talking
about but back in those days they didn't
even know the difference between cardio
and [ __ ] anabolic and aerobic
exercise they didn't even know what that
was
yeah i kind of feel like uh i mean if
you're a working class you're probably
just so [ __ ] tired from working seven
days a week in a [ __ ] factory that
you didn't even like think about it and
what they were doing and then if you
were upper class you just sat around in
red and like maybe maybe walked around
and ate and got fat and got gout right
so right
and they didn't know the difference
between anabolic and aerobic exercise
they mostly did aerobic exercise which
was just repetition moving something on
a damn machine or picking things up
and you could do that all day long and
not gain any muscle mass just won't
happen
i don't know arnold schwarzenegger will
tell you that they made he and his buddy
[ __ ]
from sardinia what was his name [ __ ]
little little what's his name he's
another little champion
they would sit there and make [ __ ]
brick walls all [ __ ] day and that was
nothing for them
they would get smaller doing that and
then you go to the gym and [ __ ] lift
500 pounds two or three times and there
you go
because it's concentrated you'll build a
muscle on that
but not laying bricks
and that's what these skinny little
[ __ ] did laid bricks and
[ __ ] like i said they yeah
this was uh before they actually had
like the concept of weekends and stuff
like that so it's like they just worked
like 12 hours a day work themselves down
six or seven days a week yeah and so
they were too tired when they got home
to like exercise they did it on a shitty
diet or anything yeah and they ate
shitty food also so you know you can't
really blame them for not being super in
shape
they didn't really have that luxury no
no um their growth were stunned by the
time they were eight well that bitty
shoulders bad too yeah um you know
because your childhood nutrition that
does uh play a large part very very low
protein intake in their early formative
years they [ __ ] [ __ ] their
skeletons up they were little if you
look at the doorways and the way they
made things even up to the 50s they were
kind of small
well like i said there's not i mean once
you grow into adulthood there's not
really a lot that you can do to alter
that i mean you can but not
you know
yeah not a lot a lot of [ __ ] happens in
childhood that you can't alter later tb
drugger says so i just realized today
the voltaire you guys have talked about
is lara voltaire yeah that's right he
has a youtube channel yeah uh it seems
like the world got a little smaller yeah
yeah
um yeah i'm friends with her ex we grew
up i actually didn't know until recently
that he had a youtube channel called
lara voltaire and i started watching and
i'm like this is delightful
he has well he has like a tiny well he
has a house in mexico city
and he has a tiny tiny new york
apartment and he has some stuff like he
does a little live stream like every
month or something and then he does like
decorating [ __ ] like around his little
tiny apartment and it's delightful yeah
he seems like a delightful person
and um you know it's cool like
how you can goth your [ __ ] out i think
his apartment is maybe 500 square feet
or something
um
but he has like a lot of good ideas for
how to like make things and [ __ ] like
that so like diy and stuff
um and he like i said he seems like a
like a nice dude yeah voltaire's ex-wife
is a good buddy of mine from boston
[ __ ] tonya [ __ ] yeah
she was cool too crazy
[ __ ] crazy but and then i've met
voltaire once
we talk about time he came to ibarr once
yeah well he's been to eyebar a couple
times right but he's been around forever
he seems to be a good dude
you know i first became aware of his
music in the 90s yeah
he's like
goth but funny yeah he's a really really
good
lyricist yeah
like his lyrics are very very funny yeah
and he's jewish too so our jewish
listeners will [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
probably enjoy him because he makes fun
of the fact that he's [ __ ] jewish in
gothic
just from watching his videos
um our age he's our age
[ __ ] gothic music with [ __ ] jewish
[ __ ]
music [ __ ] yiddish [ __ ] violins
going yeah [ __ ] funny
i like that though yeah but i think
we're on the roof he seems like
he just seems like a nice dude yeah i
don't know him but like i've maybe said
hi to him one time
but your ex-wife always talks [ __ ] about
you well that's just that comes with
that comes with the territory
that comes up yeah it's just the same
[ __ ] you know i'd be like yeah okay so
he's a dude okay
yeah yeah you all kind of suck to
greater degrees
your ex-wives always say the same thing
okay wait which is what
i ain't gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] wait wait
we're at zero
it went red again
i'm just i'm not going to say anything
until they go
green again
come on you can do it there's a bad
green again that was that i don't know
where it was at
you guys can remind me where i left off
i got cut off somewhere
it probably doesn't matter it probably
doesn't yeah
um well yeah we were talking about
voltaire because somebody talked about
that
and you were talking about
how your ex-wife always says [ __ ] about
yeah your ex-wives always say the same
things about the ex-husbands always
which is what i'm curious oh that
[ __ ] cheats or that
motherfucker's always doing this and he
can't keep it in his pants or uh
[ __ ] lies or it's always the
same [ __ ] i didn't say that about my ex
because that wasn't just true but there
were well that's the common one though
is [ __ ] yeah but is it true
though
if it's true then there's no reason why
people shouldn't say there's no way of
knowing well there is a way of knowing i
mean there is an objective truth out
there to be discovered
maybe he did [ __ ] around i don't know in
which case
she has a legitimate grievance
um
well you have to i didn't say that about
my ex because i don't because i don't
think that happened
but they're going to get me in trouble
and i'm not i'm not saying but they're
i'm just saying that that's not like a
universal look look look look i know
tanya very well
okay some of the [ __ ] that she says i
take with a grain of salt
i just know her real well
okay
for all i know she was cheating you know
you don't know you don't know well i'm
not i i don't have a dog in that fight
right i don't know her in a comment
you're trying to get me to come no i'm
just asking no i was asking for you to
not necessarily what her beef was but
just like what the general beef was
because you said that i did give you the
general beef yeah okay yeah like i said
it's not a general beef that's just
because i didn't have that beef about my
ex because i don't think that was true
that [ __ ] is an [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] cheating or oh he's doing this
and that and you never really can't tell
what's true
you always try to you project a lot you
think the average woman is like you and
yours nothing average about you nothing
well thank you if you were average i
wouldn't be with you [ __ ] no there's
nothing average or normal about you
you say that you say that like it's a
bad thing uh no it says it's okay it's
good because the uh the the average one
was very superficial very he sounded
very deep well no that's good yeah
i guess the average woman's very
superficial [ __ ] they're not adorable
oh [ __ ] um okay no
you've seen me with average women and
you hated them
better than this
you're better than me they were cute
though
well yeah that's what you always said
that's all that mattered at the time but
though that's the average
now you understand
well no that's the average
don't don't like don't condescend to me
no i'm not kind of i understand i'm just
trying to give you the baseline that
that was no i know that you were you
it's just that see jenny would not knew
knows who i was dating before me and
jenny were a couple
and she would just be like
[ __ ]
she just was like i was like really
excited is that the best she can do
she's just appalled but the thing is
though it's like that's av that was
and she's like yeah but she's cute yeah
well she was like she wasn't physically
average but until personality wise
that's the average woman they're like
that
that's the way they are and that's all
dudes care about ladies no
[Laughter]
see how see how she's doing see how she
does it i thought that guys you guys
understand what i'm talking about
there's a bass line that that is kind of
tolerable and that was real close to the
[ __ ] tolerable bass line that's the
way most of them are
so guys just kind of develop around that
we're like yeah okay i can run with that
for now anybody get sick of that i'll
replace it with another one
that's really is what's going on it's
like it's like a machine it's like it's
like a system especially when you're
young well yeah but
you say that
like women haven't figured out that out
by the time they're like 10 years old
they're the ones that you hated in
school that's the average
i know that yeah like i said i figured
that out when i was younger
when i say these things that you get
offended about i don't know why you get
offended because i'm not offended it's
just
i'm offended that you think that i don't
know what's going on okay you talk to me
like i don't understand that was the
reaction i got out of you you're like
well i thought you were better than that
that's all
but you're not no i was trying to get
laid at that time
i was trying to get laid make girls try
to get lazy they were just trying to get
laid you're reading into it i was trying
to get laid you know
that's all it was
it was getting late it wasn't trying i
was getting late
yeah yeah uh cheryl says gothic
homemaking is a [ __ ] honestly my
favorite thing about his channel
is i mean i like when he goes to all the
different like goth bars and [ __ ] like
that in different places he did like a
whole thing of like mexico city he did a
whole thing where
he went to different monster themed bars
like a world which i thought was cool
but honestly
my favorite thing is when he makes
things to go in his tiny tiny tiny ass
apartment because
i i don't know i'm fascinated by
people's like storage solutions when
they're in a very very small space how
they can got that [ __ ] out i'm really
into that i like that
he still he just put up a um
one of his live streams i think it's
like two and a half hours long
and he just put it up a couple days ago
i put in my watch later but i haven't
watched it yet so you know
cheryl says
oh wait it went red
no
come on charlotte uh
jenny's the best
i am are they
i don't see that voltaire is cuban too
right he is yeah yeah yeah he's probably
from here isn't he
um
i think he's not we've seen him here so
i think he's from here well he hangs out
here because he has played shows here
okay
the cuban connection is not as done
through the florida i don't know if he's
from here he lives in new york city
yeah everybody from new york doesn't
matter though he's probably from no he
has an apartment in new york city i
don't know if he was born here i don't
think so
but uh his fiancee is japanese but i
think she
lived in mexico city and i think they
have a house in mexico city as well yeah
because they do a lot of videos down
there as well
but
yeah he's uh delightful so lara voltaire
if you uh are not onto that and his
music is delightful as well so you
should probably check it out it's very
very funny
um so let's see where was i i may have a
couple pictures of volteers flicking x
we'll see back when i hang out with her
let's see if i have any
no fear
no i don't
i used to
me and her back in the day
all right so i think i talked about this
what the [ __ ] is going on what is going
on
when is the last time
this much
when is the last time we've had this
much [ __ ] trouble terrible
i mean
yeah this is making me very very upset
all right so while it's green
now i'm gonna like have to like hurry up
and get through this [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
which is hard because like i said i'm
getting mad so i'm like drinking don't
give away
man
easy for you to say no
you didn't spend hours and hours like
researching you can always do it again
we can always do it again i don't want
to do that though okay this is like i
don't want to do like [ __ ] four parts
come on i gotta like edit this [ __ ]
together okay
so uh so yeah so the sanitarium like i
said massive [ __ ] place
so it had an experimental kitchen right
so ella who i think was dr kellogg's
wife she had a cooking school at the
place and she taught classes and like
had enough publishing a cookbook which
is called science in the kitchen and she
had all these kind of like vegetarian
recipes all this kind of [ __ ] in there
and uh i think i brought this up earlier
but i don't know if it got cut off or
not and there it goes right i don't know
if it got cut off or not but they
developed this thing called nutaline
which like it's made from uh peanuts and
it was a meat substitute
and they also had something called uh
protozoa protos
which was kind of like grains nuts like
mixed together um you know also a meat
substitute and uh you know developed
various kind of nut butters so as i
mentioned earlier
uh dr kellogg was a big advocate of and
it's zero again
this is making me so angry
so he's a big advocate of
most diseases are caused by like some
[ __ ] uh weird intestinal flora in
your uh intestines
so a lot of his uh
a lot of his recipes were meant to
alleviate that uh we mentioned earlier
that he was a big advocate of eating
half your yogurt and shooting half your
yogurt up your butt because it had like
some good bacteria in there that were
supposed to
clean out your intestines uh he was a
big advocate of that he's a big advocate
of enemas in general
not just yogurt um
he actually invented
enema machines so at the at the spa
there the battle creek sanitarium
i believe they had a whole entire room
of anima machines
i think that he patented ian that would
shoot like x amount of
water or yogurt or whatever water yogurt
coffee whatever you wanted to [ __ ] up
there um it would shoot it up your butt
and you know it it kept track of how
much stuff was going up your butt he was
really into like having a really clean
bowel is is what i'm saying
like i said not crazy
but
a little weird thing to have an
obsession about a little weird thing
i don't know
i'm of two minds about it i'm of two
minds about it it is good
in some ways
like yeah
just have all that [ __ ] moving through
there but
it's weird to be like obsessed about it
though
you know yeah
it's a fine line i got you it's violin
you were at massive [ __ ] play yeah
so
you know
so like i said his thing
the only thing i feel like he well not
the only thing but one of the only
things like uh diet wise
he was more of an advocate of low
protein diets he wanted high fiber diets
um and stuff that would like have a
laxative effect
which is weird because i feel like he
wasn't really into like caffeinated
drinks like coffee and stuff even though
coffee is like a big laxative
so
you'd think that he'd want you to drink
like gallons of gallons of coffee
that'll clean you right out
just saying
um
yeah so
yogurt up your butt there it's here's
the here's the quote about it
um
he says like i said
pint of yogurt a day
half of it you eat how fat you shoot up
your butt
uh the quote is thus planting the
protective germs where they are most
needed and may render most effective
service protected germs that's a nice
way to put it
effective service
it'll make you poop more so you know
uh i want you to like clean out your
bells
i just can't i can't get past that okay
um also
everybody that would stay there at this
place
uh you'd have breathing exercises like i
said not that weird um you know probably
weird watching people do it but not
weird in the aggregate
um they do like little marches around
and stuff
um
he was also real into
photo therapy or like light therapy
which like i said sounds kind of weird
and new agey but
again not that weird because
some people have
like seasonal depression caused by
darkness blah blah blah
and they do actually like advocate
putting them over like sunlight or
artificial sunlight and that does
improve their mood or like seems to
so that's strange from our point of view
probably back then they probably thought
it was like wacky and stuff but not all
that weird but he was like really into
like light therapy as well
now uh so again i think i mentioned
earlier that he had actually been to
medical school so he wasn't a quack he
was actually a doctor
he actually was a surgeon
crazy
it's just it's just it's making me so
mad
come on okay
where was i
now let's get into the masturbation
because i have to give it to the
masterpiece well i thought it just
the light just went green so i thought
that that'd be good if people were just
like coming back on after the [ __ ]
uh you know
after we were having problems that's
funny
um okay so dr kellogg i will say even
though he was a surgeon and he did do
surgeries
um
he was kind of like look i don't really
like to do surgeries if people don't
need them which you know that seems like
a pretty reasonable uh you know stance
to take
but
like many other seventh-day adventists
not a big fan of sex in general
not uh really not a big fan of
masturbation
and so anytime you could
that's [ __ ] funny anytime you could
break you know he was probably like
[ __ ] jerking it 24 7. just like maybe
why that [ __ ] projected i kind of feel
like maybe i don't like i don't know i
don't want to cast aspersions a dude's
dead now
maybe he was the very rare exception
that wasn't like that
but in my experience the more that
people like rail about something
the more they're doing that [ __ ]
about other people masturbating which
again doesn't have anything to do with
you there's a [ __ ] issue there man
then
maybe that's your problem yeah maybe not
other people not saying that's the case
here i'm just saying
maybe maybe
so he was like not really in about well
okay so he had a problem with
masturbation because
he thought that
well he thought that like sexual
anything was
i don't know depleting your life force
or something like that
masturbation in particular he called it
something like and i'm paraphrasing
killing yourself by your own hand that's
what he called it
you're removing your own life essence
i kind of feel like that's how he felt
about it yeah which wasn't a crazy point
of view at the time um he wasn't the
only one that thought that he doesn't
know much about biology well no but
you know i'm just saying that he wasn't
the only [ __ ] that was saying
[ __ ] like that i do kind of feel like
people there was like a small i don't
think it was mainstream or anything but
there was like a
substantial
minority of people let's call it that
that
thought that
jerk in it was some kind of like not
only was that physically affecting your
health but that was like uh
you know pointing toward your moral
degeneracy also like it was kind of like
you know i mean and i i i feel like he
kind of had that as well
so um
which if he just had that point of view
fine but
the thing that he did advocate though
is that
if uh little boys
were too into again jerking it
which he called
local uncleanliness
what was it local to oh [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] i'm just like not talking when
it's red because why bother okay it's
green
okay so he thinks that
local uncleanliness yeah
is leading
which is gonna like not wipe your ass or
something that's that look like this
yeah in your butthole area yeah
that's what it sounds like
[ __ ] are nuts man
victoria well
like i said
you know man shit's going red
man we're like getting in the flow and
we're funny yeah
so
the fact that he thought that okay it
would be fine if you just thought that
everyone would think you were nuts and
no one wanted to hang out with you or
invite you to parties or anything but
fine
but
problem is you have thoughts like this
and they lead you to actually do things
which is where the problem arises
because
he actually advocated
um
circumcision for both males and females
for too much masturbation as little
children
so cutting off someone clitorectomy yes
oh man it must be badass also a big
advocate of little boys little girls uh
jerking it too much
or you know doing whatever you do
um strapping into the bed
cutting off various parts so you know
you're [ __ ] crazy not a fan of that
not a fan of that uh that's that's
that's not cool
so you know are we middle eastern [ __ ]
there that's what i'm saying yeah so
like i said
good ideas
in the form of
hey let's eat more vegetables and not as
much meat or meat substitutes he
also later on i will say in case
he was actually um
instrumental in uh doing like soy milk i
think he uh patented the first soy milk
actually back in [ __ ] the early 20th
century
big advocate of like uh nut butters meat
substitutes
all kind of like soy things which like i
said very very much ahead of his time so
like i said cool um
had a lot of patents and like uh
medical type stuff not all of which were
crazy although some of them were
uh but yeah a big into
like i said he wasn't really into
circumcision as just like oh let's
circumcise everybody
he was into circumcision male and female
if you were masturbating too much he was
like that was which like i said
i can't advocate that sorry uh that's
pretty [ __ ] up
so as i said a lot of celebrities went
to this place and it's going red again
come on
this is so frustrating terrible it's so
frustrating
yeah like [ __ ] the curse of kellogg
is upon this yeah yeah he's like [ __ ]
haunting this [ __ ] i'm gonna mush it
down totally
although i don't think it's that it
seems unrelated
yeah we
don't usually have this problem yeah
it's just uh
it's the service
it's back well well no
it's not
click back there it is back yeah it's
the service
i guess i don't know what they're doing
but yeah
so yeah so they did have a lot of
celebrities come there
now let's talk a little bit about before
we get cut off again so let's talk a
little bit about uh corn flakes now like
i mentioned earlier
uh john harvey kellogg
um
he was very into like vegetarian foods
and as i mentioned at the time uh there
wasn't really any kind of dedicated
breakfast food you basically just ate
whatever like [ __ ] was left over from
the night before usually meat uh you
just reheated it and whatever fat you
had left over and you just ate that for
breakfast then you went off to the
factory or the coal mine or whatever the
[ __ ]
um so
kellogg was trying to
establish a bland
uh easy to prepare
because grains were very difficult to
prepare back in those days
um so something that was easy to prepare
something that he perceived as healthy
something he perceived as bland tasting
because it wouldn't make you want to
like touch yourself so there was that
yeah
food that doesn't make you want to jerk
off what it's
i'm not even making that up i'm not
making that up
that was one of the things
that was one of the things reminds me of
the [ __ ] that chinese believe that
drinking and eating certain things make
you hot or cold
i don't really understand that either
honestly
one thing that i laughed at yeah when i
was researching the show
dr kellogg actually thought like people
that were he could recognize
allegedly people that were chronic
masturbate [ __ ]
we did zero again
he could recognize people that were
chronic [ __ ] because they liked
spicy foods yeah and had round shoulders
oh [ __ ] so all of india and people that
didn't work out and i was like dude i'm
jerking i'm in trouble
i mean true but okay but yeah so
so there's that [ __ ] doesn't
know what he's talking about he's making
[ __ ] up of course not but like i said
everyone's a little bit of good a little
bit of bad this dude had some crazy
ideas he had some good ideas too
now
uh so yeah so he was really into like i
said vegetarian diet very bland food
because he thought that that would not
excite people's like sexual you know
feelings or anything like that um
so
he starts in 1877. he starts [ __ ]
around with something he wants something
that's like a breakfast food but it's
kind of bland but like a little bit
softer
he wanted something that was like easy
to chew because
he was big into this dude
named horace fletcher
who
horace fletcher
he had the idea this is not true yeah
back then that you should chew your food
40 times before swallowing it
because it broke it down
easier i guess uh and it made the job
easier for your stomach i don't i don't
know
so but kellogg was on board with that so
he's like okay uh you know i'm down with
that they even had like a little chewing
song chew everything 40 times choo choo
choo that's the thing to do
they had a little [ __ ] rhyme about it
and everything
so what he did in this endeavor
uh you know because he wanted something
that was easy to eat very easy to
prepare in the morning
so he comes up with this dough
and it's like
wheat oats they baked it at very high
temperatures for a long time uh which
they thought would break down the starch
molecules in the grain
then after it was broken apart uh
kellogg would break it into crumbs
now this cereal which was just like you
know the crumbs of the baked
uh you know wheat oats and corn mixture
um he originally called it
granula
now
there was another competing company
a guy named james caleb jackson
he had a wheat cereal that he already
called granula so he's like [ __ ] you
can't call it that
so at that point kellogg's like okay
well i'm gonna call it granola
there you go now
isn't it funny that he caught he wasn't
the first one to come up with it this
other [ __ ] did or granola
it's all about branding yeah that's just
how that goes so i hate to tell you but
yeah so he called it granola
uh so he started like selling it under
that name now he just [ __ ] went red
god damn it this is really pissing me
off should we end this show no because
i'm not done i still have like so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] i gotta do yeah we'll be
able to get through it okay it's green
i don't know if it's stopped or not
no it hasn't stopped it hasn't stopped
okay so no i'm still well okay
okay it's green all right it's good i
mean usually when it goes red i just
right
but we don't really know
but i don't really know it's a whatever
okay whatever
uh so yeah granola
now at this point
it's 1890 they started selling granola
to the patients at the battle creek
sanitarium at first
but then
he decides he's going to start a company
called the sanitas sanitos
food company it's very sanitary
uh and he's gonna like sniff different
foods
now
the very famous corn flakes that
kellogg's is probably best known for
nowadays a little bit of controversy
about how everybody came up with that
legend goes
that somebody like made some dough and
like left it out overnight and then
they're like oh i wonder like this all
dried out i wonder what would it taste
like if we did this on the other
but there's some kind of like because i
don't know if you guys know but like
[ __ ] dr john kellogg and his brother
will
there was a really lo like lifelong
rivalry between the two of them
and
uh
there was like a lot of legal wrangling
about the name kellogg which will
actually got the eventual rights to
but yeah it was a whole thing which you
know hopefully i'll get into if we don't
[ __ ] lose the [ __ ] stream again
uh so
ella who's the wife
and will
they both have their own stories about
how this [ __ ] corn flake situation
came about
so
they have this dough
um
now ella says she said that oh we should
take this dough and like roll it out
right
and then into sheets and then
you know she says oh i said to do that
and then dr john said okay we'll have
these like rollers and we'll make them
and that's you know we'll make them for
the process for that
and
late like other things like john said
later oh i love corn flakes and there
was that and then will said no it was my
idea
somebody said it was an accident they
left the dough out overnight and it
dried out and it's like they did this
thing it was like you know like i said
it was an accident but
so nobody knows exactly where it came
from but the gist of it was
that they got to the point where this
dough was like rolled out into thin
sheets they kind of
left it to dry out and then they baked
it and it made these like fantastic
little flakes which they thought hey we
can sell that to some [ __ ] because
that's kind of good you know
although i will say will
actually had the brother he actually had
the idea we should add some sugar to
that [ __ ] and dr john kellogg said
absolutely not because sugar might
excite somebody's sexual tension yeah
you might [ __ ] a [ __ ] if you put
some sugar i mean you know you might
stick your dick in jerks you might jerk
or you might touch yourself
[Laughter]
and we can't have that we can't have
that
so no we're not going to talk about
carbs now
carbs and calories has nothing to do
with it it's just i mean you might get
some sugar you might jerk it
it's just hilarious i mean you never
know about the thinking of the time they
didn't know the thinking of the time
i mean i'm willing to give them some of
the benefit of that alexander but
you know
uh but yeah so
regardless of whoever came up with the
original plan yeah uh they did actually
uh come up with the cornflake concept
and they actually did patent it
in
1895 i believe uh er and it was the
patent was issued in 1896 in spring of
1896 to john harvey kellogg alone
so that's why there was some controversy
because he just patented it and his wife
and his brother were both were like well
we kind of came up with that [ __ ] too
why isn't our name on that [ __ ] but you
know that was the whole thing i mean the
thing about it is that dr john kellogg
and his brother will
they kind of had a lifelong uh
rivalry like i said and it wasn't really
resolved
even after dr kellogg died
even though
yeah there was a whole thing having to
do with that
now
initially they marketed these
flaked
cereal things
as granos like i said
um
they also
the patents that they got
um actually extended to but also like
other kinds of grains too so he could
like with other kinds of things like
other kinds of cereals and they did
so
the first year that they put this these
flexion they actually sold like a [ __ ]
ton of the stuff right
under the name granos or however the
[ __ ] you pronounce it
so
but they
kind of kept trying to innovate uh so
they had some corn they had some rice uh
you know wheat they were trying to do
like other things with it to see what
was going on
now 1898
uh they
released a batch of something called
sanitas which
nowadays nobody would call it that
because that sounds like a maxi pad
but it does but back then uh i'm sure
that sounded like really healthy and
everything but yeah like i said now
nowadays that sounds like a maxi pad but
back then
sanitize toasted corn flakes that's what
they called it
um and then they so they
were pretty successful with that
then they did another version of it in
1902 which was like uh had a longer
shelf life
and so then they had the flakes and then
they also had like biscuits which i'm
guessing were kind of like weetabix
you know what i mean if you we have
weetabix here in the us but i kind of
feel like it's more of a thing in europe
it's kind of yeah they're like those big
biscuits and you like put it in like
kind of hot milk and like break it up
you know what i mean
it's kind of like uh
frosted mini wheats but without the
frost
it's like that
so will kellogg who is the brother
so
he kind of did his own thing as well
and again i said he was kind of like hey
let's put sugar on the [ __ ] because that
would probably make it taste better
he knew what was up
uh dr john again absolutely not would
not add sugar to the stuff because that
wasn't allowed
so you know like i said that might make
somebody masturbate somewhere so we
can't have that
uh so at that point 1906 was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] um he starts his own company
which is called the battle creek toasted
cornflake company
and
this him starting his own company that
was kind of like the start i mean they
were kind of like ravels before but now
for real now they have like two rival
companies that are making essentially
the same thing but he's like might have
sugar so i win so there was that
um
yeah and it
it should be noted that it was will's
you know the brother the one that had
wanted added add sugar
it was his company because they he they
sued later like dr john sued will it's
like well you can't call it kellogg
because that's my name too and then like
they sued each other and then wolves
like yeah [ __ ] you i'm adding sugar and
then uh the court eventually decided
that will
have the rights to the kellogg name
so the corn flakes that you have
nowadays that have sugar on them
that's because will
uh eventually won the lawsuit not dr
john
with the the sugar as opposed to the
non-gender guy just saying
now there were some other competitors
going on as well like i said they were
the first people to do the whole like
[ __ ] cornflake thing they were the
inventors but
uh another guy named c.w post
who you might recognize
he was actually uh had gone to the
battle creek sanitarium uh in 1891. if
you guys know who's who what post is
that we have a cereal brand here i don't
know if it still exists it was called cw
it does cereal
they had a lot of good [ __ ] i think they
had raisin bran wasn't there wasn't that
wait was it yeah i think post was uh
yeah i think brazen brand was both
[ __ ] and uh she was great there's
already she was great yeah still around
as far as i know
yeah
so he was a christian scientist so
who knew that the like the history of
cereal was there yeah
it is religious i mean back in those
days a lot of it was
so cw post had been at the sanitarium
he was a christian scientist who i don't
know if you guys know but
christian scientists are kind of like
they're
pretty cool as sects go but they're very
against
medical science they kind of feel like
they're more like look if god doesn't
heal us then [ __ ] it will i
that's the simplification but that's
kind of still like that
um
i don't well
here's the thing
i knew a couple christian scientists in
the 90s so i don't know if that's like
still the way it is but i kind of feel
like well if we're gonna get this
disease and die then that's god god's
will we don't
i don't know if they go as far as like
because you know how jehovah's witnesses
won't get even get like blood
transfusions and stuff yeah i thought
christian scientists were kind of like
adjacent to that but i don't know if
there's like different there might be
different like kind of
where that [ __ ] school's a thought on
that where that [ __ ] came from wasn't as
crazy as you think because well it never
is back in the day when they started
that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] 17 in the 1800s
they didn't want to deal with the
medical [ __ ]
establishment made a lot of sense back
then because [ __ ] medicine was a
bunch of quackery
and if you stayed away from it probably
odds are you're probably better off back
then i mean in the aggregate probably
just because they didn't really know
what they were doing modern era you're
probably better going to a doctor for
most things right back then probably not
because they didn't know what the [ __ ]
they were doing right they were making
[ __ ] up
so they were like well just put it in
god's hands you'd probably be all right
better than putting putting in that
guy's hands and they were probably right
half of well if god lets you die then
that's yeah [ __ ] happens you're sorry
you're sick you'll either get better or
you won't if you go to that dude he'll
probably kill you you're probably better
off he just sit here
and there was probably something to that
back in the 17th and the 1800s
but that's saying something about
medical care but yeah it's like probably
better just to knock you out
by the time but by the time the 30s had
rolled around you're better off going to
the doctor uh yeah yeah yeah that's
that's a long time ago that that
happened yeah
uh but yeah
so where was i
1930s for you youngsters by the time the
1930s rolled around you were better off
going to the doctor
sarah says did we talk about the brother
already yeah we're talking about that
now we're talking about will
how he wanted to like add sugar to stuff
and dr john said no
but then will sued or like they sued
each other essentially is what happened
uh and will got the rights to the name
so then we were talking about cw post so
he was out